HASHTAG WARS!
>> IT IS NOT AN ACTUAL WAR, IT
IS A WORD WAR, IT IS NOT --
>> YOU THROW THE TERMS AROUND
>> Chris: THE FIRST GAME OF
THE NBA FINALS WAS TONIGHT, WITH
THE MIAMI HEAT FACING SAN
ANTONIO SPURS, THE SPURS ARE
FULL OF GERIATIC PLAYERS LIKE
TIM DUNCAN.
SO IN HONOR OF THE SPURS
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS #ELDERLYNBA
EXAMPLES ARE LAMAR OLD-MAN,
MANUTE THIS BOL OF SOUP IS COLD,
OR I'VE CHRIS PAULEN AND I CAN'T
GET UP.
>> ALL RIGHT.
I AM PUTTING 60-SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND GO.
>> PAUL F. TOMPKINS.
>> THE LOS ANGELES CLIPPERS OF
COUPONS FOR CAT FOOD WHICH THEY
ARE SECRETLY EATING.
>> Chris: POINTS. POINTS.
BRETT GELMAN.
>> KARL MALONELY BECAUSE ALL MY
FRIENDS ARE DEAD.
>> Chris: POINTS.
PAUL F. AGAIN.
>> THE PHILADELPHIA 76ERS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
YES.
POINTS.
>> HEATHER.
>> PHOENIX SONS NEVER VISIT ME
ANYMORE.
>> Chris: POINTS.
>> SCOTTIE I WAS IN THE FIRST
PRODUCTION OF PIPPIN.
>> Chris: OH, THAT IS HARD.
POINTS.
PAUL TOMPKINS.
>> JUST PUT MY TEETH IN A CUP
AND NOTHING BUT NET.
>> Chris: POINTS.
HEATHER ANNE CAMPBELL.
>> THE INDIANA PACEMAKERS.
>> Chris: YES.
GOOD.
POINTS.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: BRETT GELMAN.
>> KEVIN COSTNER IS SURE TO GET
AN OSCAR ROBINSON FOR HIS
WONDERFUL PERFORMANCE IN DANCING
WITH THE WOLVES.
>> Chris: OH GOD
>> OH MY GOD.